good morning Hank it's Tuesday but this
video was filmed in the past I mean I
guess that's always true but it's more
true than usual this time I'm taking a
week or two away from the internet to
work so this video was actually filmed
nine days ago has anything interesting
happened in the last nine days has a
shocking scandal gripped the nation
probably it seems like shocking scandals
gripped the nation every week and
horrify and/or thrill us so much that we
think now this is a properly shocking
scandal and it is until the next week
when there is a new shocking scandal as
Dorothy Parker said a long long time ago
what fresh hell is this but let us not
talk of health and freshness let's
answer real questions from real
nerdfighters because it's question
Tuesday what's in the box is okay
absolutely true story I recently opened
one of the boxes and I was stunned to
find what's inside in fact I'll just
show you so we have here a box I'm just
gonna open it and as you'll see what's
inside of this box is another box you
Caterpillar's know they'll turn into
butterflies or while they're building
the cocoon or they just like what the
heck am i doing well we know the
butterfly seemed to be able to remember
smells from when they were caterpillars
although admittedly that's not quite the
same thing as self-awareness but then
again do humans know what they're doing
as they mature or are they just like
what the heck am i doing how do you cope
with uncertainty quite poorly I
desperately want to be able to close the
loop on my thoughts like I really want
to be able to convince myself that
something really anything is absolutely
certain on the other hand I would argue
that uncertainty is maybe a little
underappreciated in contemporary
discourse like it sometimes feels as if
you're supposed to begin every
conversation not only with a position
but with absolute certainty that your
position is correct and I personally
find it difficult to even be certain
about the proposition that I'm like an
actual human being let alone what the
top marginal income tax rate should be
in the United States what's your
favorite word right now nonsense Oriole
what are you looking forward to most
about VidCon I really love the annual
nerdfighter meetup because we get to
talk about future plans for crash course
and other stuff how's life post 100 days
good I just finished my first half
marathon in a time of two hours and
seven minutes meaning that if I can just
reduce my time by like an hour I'll be a
world-class runner and one of us into
the mountain goats but where should I
start their new album just came out it's
called Goths and it's one of my
favorites it really took me back into my
past with an intensity I haven't felt in
a long time that said I always recommend
that you start with the album all hail
West Texas my brother's expecting a baby
soon how can I prepare to be
great-aunt well you're not actually
gonna be a great-aunt you're just gonna
be a regular aunt until like your
brother's kid has a baby of its own then
you'll be a great no wait you meant like
how can I prepare to be an excellent
aunt don't worry about it you're gonna
be great
well you'll be regular but you know what
I mean what's your favorite pasta shape
the bowtie one favorite regular shape
spiral favorite painting probably this
one by Raymond Pettibon favorite
superhero Batman
no I'm just kidding Batman isn't a
superhero he's a rich person my favorite
comic book superhero at the moment is
probably MS Marvel favorite dog breed
mutts although I'm also partial to what
Alice calls Willy dogs how is Willy um
unfortunately not great Willy has cancer
it's a very slow growing kind of cancer
but it is cancer he's a great dog and
he's much loved and we're hopeful he can
have a good dog life for quite a while
longer so I wanted to let you know
that's going on but we're hopeful
because he does have a relatively good
prognosis let's move on to happier news
what's going on with Russia and Trump
I said happier news how did AFC
Wimbledon manage not to score a single
goal in their final six games happier
news Ashley Ford asks I got engaged last
night and I'm wondering what's your best
advice for a long and happy marriage
there we go some proper happy news
congratulations the world goes on people
fall in love hope that thing with
feathers refuses to be shushed
as to your question I posed it to Sara
and she reminded me of this Philip
Larkin poem that ends we should be
careful of each other we should be kind
while there is still time Hank let us be
careful of each other and kind I'll see
you on Friday